mais d'abord je crois comme beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes on a
découvert eric zemmour par la nature ou
par les vidéos youtube beaucoup sont
tombés dessus par hasard peut-être comme
d'ailleurs beaucoup de jeunes ont du
regarder cette émission soir dix ans
mais qui est cet homme en fait on nous
présente comme le mal absolu comme le
démon est en fait qui après l'avoir
écouté parce qu'une fois qu'on a on est
sorti des caricatures et qu'on allait
dans le fond des yeux beaucoup moins d'
attaque beaucoup d'agressivité et
beaucoup ce soir en plus qu'on pense
qu'il voulait dire et moi je fais partie
de cette génération je pense qui a
réussi à se former politiquement
sont certains aspects littéraire
historiquement en écoutant eric zemmour
si on est pas si on n'est pas couché là
aussi on est visiblement bien sûr va
bientôt aller se coucher si on n'est pas
couché mais aussi dans ses livres et je
crois que c'est ce qui a fait la
différence aujourd'hui s'il ya un
mouvement de jeunes qui rassemble
quasiment dix mille personnes en tout
c'est bien quelle raison il ya une lame
de fond à tout ça c'est libération qui a
pu enfin trouvé quelqu'un qui sur les
plateaux débattait à face à plusieurs
personnes c'est encore le cas ce soir où
il n'ya pas de cadeau qui lui sont faits
avec beaucoup d'agressivité d'ailleurs
tandis qu'avec des mots pour coup et
c'est je crois qu'il faut l'en remercier
je crois que vous avez le remerciement
de toute une génération
et le fait dans le calme et justement
ses parents l'être humain des idées
politiques et ça je crois que ce soir
tout a été illustrée c'est là les
caricatures l'extrême gauche toujours
plus virulente les unes que les autres
les attaques les attaques sur des
détails au lieu de rentrer dans le son
est à chaque fois qu'on a pu aborder des
sujets intéressants comme avec monsieur
vardon sur sur la rs tout un tas de
sujets je pense que les français
comprennent ce qui se passe en france
est ce qu a des idées du candidat eric
zemmour sur lesquels vous dit en
désaccord ou bien vous êtes d'accord
avec lui sur surtout non très peu parce
que je crois qu'aujourd'hui l'essentiel
c'est quand même de préserver à un beau
pays qu'est la france je crois que c'est
de préserver une civilisation est
d'ailleurs sur ça que je passe quelque
chose qui me frappe dans cette tourmente
monsieur zemmour dit vive la france et
surtout vive la france par seconde
contrairement à la france soumise par ce
soit le plus important que j'ai vu là
bas et la république française ben voila
moi je crois que ce qui est important
aujourd'hui dont l'enjeu de cette
présidentielle n'était pas un enjeu de
chiffres des petits détails et stable le
but de cette prison ciel c'est de savoir
si on fait on pourra vivre dans un pays
prospère demain si on pourra aller de
l'avant si on pourra avoir de nouveau
des élites fier si on pourra de nouveau
avoir des gens qui sont heureux du grand
france si on peut pas vivre en paix
parce que ça il ya moi il ya un exemple
m'a frappé c'est que tous les gens qui
ont aujourd'hui ou qui ont connu le 11
septembre ce sujet deux jours ils
étaient environ 70 par exemple
l'endroit pour tous faisant ce sujet
ainsi cyril et ben nous dans nos vies
narration beaucoup se souviennent du
jour ils étaient où il ya eu charlie
hebdo williams bataclan oui où il ya eu
samuel patty est en fait tous ces jeunes
là sont traumatisés par tout ça et je
crois qu'à lisez-moi rapporte beaucoup
d'aplomb ça mais on l'a vu cette semaine
et je le dis de nos mères et grimaud on
a ensuite andy david ce jeune homme qui
était derrière vous au meeting qui a
reçu des menaces qui vit l'enfer vous
pour vous ça se passe comment
personnel j'ai un peu de chance je
prends évidemment énormément de menaces
et d'ailleurs je tiens à le souligner
mais ce soir des gens du mouvement
générationnel voulaient se rassembler
dans dans la barque pour garder
justement cette émission comme des
millions de personnes vivaient une ce
soir et des groupes d'extrême-gauche
encore une fois toujours les mêmes on
essayait de ont menacé et intimidé le
barman donc que je salue parce je
planais c'est quelqu'un de très bien qui
a juste voulu accueillir des jeunes qui
voulaient rien d'un débat il a été
menacé il a été menacée est d'ailleurs
tombé à vide en est un autre il ya des
agressions tous les jours contre ces
militants là qui ont pour seul crime le
fait de vouloir défendre le temps des
élections présidentielles dans une
élection démocratique c'est ça leur seul
crime et c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
menacés décapitation